les honneurs sont arrivés sur le tard
pendant des années le rôle que l'hiver
hawks a joué durant la seconde guerre
mondiale est demeuré secret pour éviter
que des communications ne tombent entre
les mains de l'ennemi
il traduisait les messages dans un
langage codé ce code c'était sa propre
langue maternelle le moc devrait
enchaîner à quoi ça ce n'est ni québec
mais s'est joint à l'armée américaine
à 94 ans il est le tout dernier
transmetteur moi que de messages codés
encore en vie il ressort que ces langues
qui nous a aidés à rester les la
démocratie le peuple qu'on est les
députés marc miller a contribué à le
faire connaître au canada je reviens
toujours à meyrin et du fait qu'on l'ait
non autochtones et que ce soit de façon
délibérée ou inconsciente arracher la
langue à son peuple
plus de 70 langues autochtones sont
parlées au canada plusieurs sont
menacées
le mois compte selon statistique canada
moins de 2500 locuteurs dans la famille
hawks on se parle maintenant en anglais
la fille de l'éveil de rats raconte
qu'enfant les élèves qui osaient parler
moi qu'à l'école était puni physiquement
kenza des acheteurs selon nos
informations le projet de loi sur les
langues autochtones qui doit être déposé
au parlement très bientôt s'inscrira
dans la volonté du gouvernement de
corriger les torts du passé
les temps ont changé à la chambre des
communes on assiste à des premières
comme lors de ce discours en moi dans
nos j'ai fait l'effort que j'ai fait 6
mois 2
de travail pour faire mon discours en
chambre mais l'homme est en fait c'est
ma femme qui m'a dit t'es plein de
matchs continuent pas de quoi non
dénommée croque une longue complexe
pas surprenant qu'elle était impossible
à déchiffrer par les ennemis de la
seconde guerre mondiale ça c'est les
devoirs qui font donc aquitaine ont
coincés qu'ils sont chez qui sont ces
jeunes hommes mais pour mark miller
cette langue est plus qu un code secret
souvent ans alors qu'en même temps la
ficelle entier de kate
j'ai 45 ans je ne comprenne pas
l'analogie mais la ficelle lente et de
canettes d'attentât mais la
communication c'est plus que ça c'est
l'image qui fait aussi dans le cerveau
qui se communique petit rentrer puis qui
sort et c'est la façon de se définir
dora hawks crois qu'il est un peu tard
pour se réapproprier la langue de son
père qu'il admire tant des noms comme
dora hawks note que tout le monde a
comme héros spider man ou superman alors
qu'elle a son père ici madeleine blé
morin radio canada à quoi ça ce n'est